[Music]
this week we've got poop rampage Oh tree
refund and legal sex
[Laughter]
hold on the note front first story
there's this New Yorker and walking here
story not gonna working I walk into you
that's that that's like a thing of me
oldest location here working oh boy yeah
you whatever your ear wants to pick up
on yeah so this New Yorker uh he was
walking race is like cooking like he's
walking so he's walking or is he like
working know what the walk the walk was
he really walking Chinese awesometown
guy yeah dude named Steve Steve Steve
here he was in the [ __ ] it international
is how you pronounce it okay okay okay
took too much Agra is it anything over
one too much [ __ ] it with the bonus
damn he's about the [ __ ] yeah so he
took too much viagra and he was just
walking on in the airport naked viagra
doesn't make you go naked okay this guy
you might be on something now wait I'm
sorry so what this was in New York
no so he's in New York he's a New Yorker
in Phuket with the raging boner boner
naked in there war you naked throwing
his feces around on the airport also
gonna drugs
yeah that sounds like some Thai heroin
or some [ __ ] I don't know anybody I
remember [ __ ] and had a boner at the
same time is that possible what he has
viagra no I I mean I don't know what
about having a boner but it'd be on the
outside why is it that whatever like the
most primitive thing that people do when
it comes like drugs or anything crazy at
your head
poop is being thrown it's like monkey
why why is it yeah why do you monkey so
poop why is it the most primitive like
this is funny we do have a sense of
humor yes let me show you guys a video
clip I don't know if I want to see
monkeys do I was at the zoo and then
this one monkey got dirt and put it over
the other monkey's head and Hewett think
it's a monkey and then on the other end
it's a glass and it's a guy showing him
a phone or something he shows him the
phone the monkey sees any goes I've seen
one with the guy showing like an
orangutan his his orangutan Rangers
orangutan Catan his his phone and then
every picture you swipe so monkey goes
[Laughter]
so cute yeah
Joe needs a monkey in his life let's
that's must fire we want to go fund me
to get Joe a monkey put a small one
though like the wanting friends because
have you seen the big ones yeah when
they get old we become MMA partners but
when they're a baby I teach them how to
ride trains and stuff what's the
friend's one called I forgot myself
have you seen Tom Kuhn the chimpanzee
that goes around and him in his Bulldog
James yeah they'd be right trains they
go shop me
the penguin yeah love the internet so
imagine like falling face-first it's
like right in their arm like you only
have to meet a bottle I'll come over
buddy grab them by the extra handle by
the arm yeah but it's slippery er than
then like a wrist
yeah yeah what if it's not very big yeah
we're all assuming you can really grab
it whatever you think this look it's
like this skin right here perfect you
know what if not always I don't think
I mean sometimes it might be a banana
sighs sometimes it's a water ball sighs
it's like a pinky sighs and it's like
hard to grab smaller than the army no
matter how big it it's like a baseball
bat right like a Louisville Slugger yeah
where's your army have a big ass so
everybody's arms no my are really
anyone's dick is always gonna be small I
bet you there's a human on earth that's
dick's bigger
that's huge what are you in Titus bro I
hope it's hands to the crack in that
case did I grab his arms you say the car
cam its economic it's made the history
this woman in Santa Clarita went to
Costco to to return her Christmas tree
on January 4th she busted a geo stupid
Chinese I feel like I don't know Chinese
people that well but white people now I
feel like our getting plastic trees cuz
I understand oh yeah absolutely
no you just buy a plastic one yeah we
have a plastic one evergreens I always
wanted a real one because of the smell
it smells great I've always had plus I
always hated the real ones because it
was so messy yes it's messy as a
[ __ ] walk by the tree get on the
creek let me get one more new one for a
real one for tyka like when he's
coherent enough to get it and then I'll
never again SAP bugs its home no it
smells great but it just smells awful
you just get a little Glade plugin yeah
that's not all you were talking about
wrestling [ __ ] all right buddy let's go
still get it they have trees that were
that good
think of it like a slinky like so it's
like what's called up at the top and we
drop it it just drops and it's
completely decorated and lit up that's
like got a dr. Seuss on shark tank it's
like a bit like a special one right yeah
yeah it's like super expensive
it'll look by an artist okay yeah but
reusable huh so like you just flatten it
when you're done what are these 60 bucks
oh wait the real ones yeah oh yeah yeah
from like 60 like to a hundred bucks
yeah that's every year 200 bucks sounds
good I want to get it if I don't have to
do the work it smells great
don't you have a tree this year you
plastic one yeah or last year I guess
significant we ordered it and then we
put it together it was fun if you're
trying to put a potato or some [ __ ] on
there right like a stupid McDonald's
fries neither
oh yeah the star the fine holder was a
star yeah really good going in your
house cuz I'm like it's not Christmas
but I'm happy I feel like just in LA
this is Santa Clarita yeah yeah I feel
like la you can't feel like Christmas
real or fake it's so warm oh I don't
mind that I'm not from the snow but at
least it gets to like 40 degrees and
gloomy yeah yeah yeah yeah I like that
cuz then but then it feels like
Christmas down here it's like said oh
you're still in shorts like boardshorts
Australia they don't really decorate as
well either down here in Elliott yeah
they're southern hemisphere Argentina my
family's Marty I might do you guys be at
the beach on Christmas that's a long
it's so weird
it sounds terrible yes too much Santa
Claus can't wear that outfit yes serpent
sleeveless Santa Claus yeah this dude
named Scott he posted up that photo with
this post here he's just like I can't
make this stuff up yesterday January 4
it's a dozen 18 at my Costco shame on
Costco shame on this loser but it's
gonna start costing all of us when word
gets out woman in line at Costco totally
nonchalant to return her Christmas tree
because it's dead on January 4th
I saw the whole thing go down with my
own two eyes about 30 minutes ago if I
didn't see it I wouldn't look to was
just to make sure someone else's - yeah
he's like really redundant with this
post but he's just like um if I didn't
see I wouldn't believe that someone had
so little moral values or lack of
conscience heartbreaking to see that she
may have needed that money so much she
lost all self-respect and dignity for it
I wish I hadn't felt so offended
initially otherwise I would have tried
to talk to her to find out what was
going on she made me sad I'm sorry
so yeah and then she just says like she
did get a refund
yeah Costco so nice yeah shame to a
small degree but didn't faze her because
she has no conscience how do you give
her a refund I don't know she's just no
that's so weird saying that's like like
buying flowers had a flower shop in the
month later it's dead I won't know
anybody just returning them everyone
especially after the holiday yeah it's a
good morn saying that Costco gave
Reserve when did you buy it it's a part
of the what do you call it like God yeah
they have a really good like return
thing that's why you see really big
lines always at Costco customer service
because there's people that game that
system like yeah they'll take it back
whenever you could have something for
years and be like yeah don't wanna is
messed up did they say when she bought
it cuz what if she did what if we're the
dick since she bought it on the third
[Music]
[Laughter]
I'm just looking at I like to I like to
see other people's viewpoints this guy
saw is saying she has no conscience or
values maybe she has high values get it
on sale she was gonna get it to get it
on sale planet in her backyard for next
Christmas right or maybe her kid was
just born up born on the 1st of January
and she wants her kid to celebrate
Christmas and you guys are total [ __ ]
little kids thank you I don't know I
don't think I could actually go back and
return a Christmas tree On January 4 I
don't think I've returned to be honest
but I have an entire like closet full of
things I'm gonna call returned I never
that's why Costco has things like this
because they know that most of us are
too damn lazy to go return [ __ ] so one
or two people it's not gonna hurt like
true cuz the majority of us we won't you
won't spend your time doing it dude I'm
good at return shoes really cuz i buy
everything like clothes everything i buy
it online and i'll buy multiples
try not at home and I'm like [ __ ]
they Bri view the return label now and I
just go to US Postal Service or whatever
online I'm like pick up a package
you know porch they take it away like
I'm gonna get five of these shoes to see
what's my size and then it just sits in
my closet for those leggings that you
have one that's why I had those that
size two pairs it was too big and I was
like way too much am you [ __ ] and it
looks great on her yeah thank you think
about this is that the lady I I'm just
imagining here like the fourth she
decides she actually undecorated her
tree loaded it into her [ __ ] car by
herself unloaded it and brought it in
there and just completely was ok with
doing this so she spent a whole day yeah
and that was like 50 bucks right imagine
if she spent that time trying to make
more money you know that's that's the
thing about bargaining and like saving
money and all that stuff it's like you
waste so much time do not eat cause it's
too expensive for our last story there
is now an app for you to get legal
consent from someone that you're trying
to have a sexual encounter with thank
goodness it's lethal injections II know
in that tinder in that tinder no I
connect we connect we're all connected
no it's a law-abiding Oh what is it law
binding contract what world are we
believe I mean is that warm besides been
using for years probably yeah yeah
prenup yeah like celebs in there the
groupies they go ahead you before you
[ __ ] up man
[ __ ] prenup I get to [ __ ] you when they
have those super parties and stuff and
then they know that a lot of [ __ ] goes
down before you go in
they have you sign NDA's and then they
take a picture of your ID they
confiscate your cell phone or something
probably well what what can make them
say though like well he drugged me and
made me sign it yeah there's always
loopholes for sure but then now it's
like their legal team can't even afford
a listing just the fact that it's an app
already feels weird like cuz what if I
took your phone like it's different than
like we're sitting with a lawyer and we
all signed this thing yes we're [ __ ]
yeah yeah it's so weird
uber lawyer instead to say like oh you
bought the bomb we about to get it
though deep contracts but at what point
and the date do you bring that up like
hey like right in the middle of about to
pull up the condom like my hold on I
need you to sign this yeah give her that
wait do you imagine maybe the beginning
like before you even go out think I even
[ __ ] about you sometimes things just
happen things just happen you just like
Netflix and chill it and then kissing
and you know what's crazy like what if
we're thinking of it like this now but
then I'm like let's save 10 years from
now like it's yeah the norm it probably
will be
it's like sign this contract and then
open the condom package and that's how
you guess it probably isn't it because
in three years from now then people that
don't do this will be frowned upon
there's like a condom machine that you
can buy at home and take this compact
one and it takes two thumb prints yes
and then it gives you a comment that's
not bad takes a dude in a chick or two
dudes oh yeah sorry sorry three chicks
yeah I don't think two chicks need a
condo for go ahead yeah but like I guess
yeah there's a different name some girls
aren't fully converted over yet
how about somewhere in between yeah so
you subscribe that handle some girls
someone even fully part yeah she's just
talked about this condom machine makes
you sign takes a photo and as a
breathalyzer it
and a witness I'm making billions that's
a lot I don't think people will use and
it's just in everyone's bedroom yeah in
hotels
it's like a butler in the closet that
one's that one that's a rotten show yeah
so this app is called legal sling legal
fling and it's not available yet in the
app stores because the first Google and
Apple they have to see if they approve
of it like if they even want it in their
app stores but this is pretty much what
it looks like and then it sounds like a
notification that's really weird like
you send it to them like the contract
and then when they open it will look
something like this and you get to
select like what they are accepting 200
explicit language interesting I wonder
how details will get I know I think
they're also saying that at any point
you can cancel the contract like let's
say you change your mind that's like
normal business kind of now the
contracts are like biting into your
ribbon they're binding to rip it up yeah
actually there's so many like people get
in trouble they [ __ ] and they feel
like remorseful and all these like 19
[ __ ] it's the logistics of it does
still don't make sense I agree that it
could be when do you apply what you pull
it when you send it to somebody
those just that questionnaire alone is
kind of weird yeah std-free like you
could still lie and there's like like no
if you lie and they find out that you're
lying you actually get to go to court
yeah but what if you don't know like
courts are whack and he was really gonna
pay a grand like it's gonna be small
claims court and it's like I thought
she's gonna be like hey do you agree to
it and then saying but this is actually
get to go through checks like at what
point in your date do that cuz we're
really for any relationship do do do do
you connect on tinder and then you send
them that thing Jesse yeah
well that's all you want me for it's
like a phone call now like the old
school like no wait three days to call
no tricolor now you know like it's now
it's like joining center of the sexes
contra camp I feel like if I was in the
situation and like let's say I'm on a
date with this dude we're just like our
first date and then he sends me this
I'll be like okay let me hold on to this
until I feel like it's gonna get there
like it's not necessarily saying I
wouldn't just be offended no I mean I
explains it I don't think I would be
offended I don't know I feel weird even
sending it I think it's offensive you if
you send it like a dick pic like just
completely yeah yeah like when is the
right time because guys don't know like
they might feel like oh I think we
really connected after that first day
let's [ __ ] dude you know what's funny
I'm gonna share a secret but so there's
a friend that we have and he was
revealing to us that he can't read when
a girl likes him or whatever right so
the girl could be in his room
make his we've been by making Ben butt
naked talking and like it is melted he's
like damn I hope she likes me yeah this
is like they're naked and cuddly yeah
yes so what's the point of being naked
you'll be like dev I guess I could kiss
her now I hope she likes me yeah that's
kind of adorable but kinda dumb with the
scenes that's pretty bad I love this
[ __ ] she's giving me I really hope
she's into me friends all right now I
hope she doesn't just want me for my
balls she likes me no owner she's
finally ready to love me
[Music]
[Music]